hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from the 1924 tournament
that we played in new york uh between
jose royal capablanca and savely
tartakover uh you guys uh requested i
show a game as today is the 80th
anniversary of jose roca blanca so like
every year on women's day we show a game
by the cuban master and what better way
uh than
uh well show a game where he truly
outshines his opponent in the end game
because he was often about simplicity he
was often about just winning the games
in the simplest possible way
and he said that um okay maybe when you
start learning chess you might be eager
to really dive into the openings but
then once the opening phases over your
opponent will just outplay you
or if you just started the middle game
then you will make some mistakes in the
uh opening you're gonna have a bad
middle game and if you have not studied
the end game at all then you're gonna
just get out played by your opponent so
he says that you should start by
studying the end game then you should uh
you know dive into the middle game and
only uh in the end you should
uh study the opening in depth of course
you have to know some basics of the
opening to be able to play but uh not
like uh you know uh uh some crazy uh
super engine line of the joker piano up
to maybe 25 moves but you have to know
that you know you don't start with h4 h5
or if you do if that's your style that's
also cool
but you have to know why you're doing it
so here we're going to show a a very
nice game and we'll
explain it with some of our own ideas
with kabab blanca's ideas also following
up by ideas of alejan and red team i so
you guys will enjoy this one uh a lot i
believe uh so capablanca with the white
pieces opens with d4 that we have e6 by
uh tatakova knight to f3 and f5 going
for the horowitz defense uh but after c4
we transpose into the dutch defense we
have knight to f6 and the bishop to g5
so every move a development bishop to e7
and knight to c3 we have castles by
tatakova and now e3 preparing to develop
the light square bishop
b6 as black already played f5 he has a
very firm grip on the e4 square he wants
to play bishop to b7 gain more control
not that or for the e for square and
then hopefully at some point put a
knight on e4 and well maybe trade off
the knight for night trade of the bishop
for bishop so that's basically black's
plan so here we have bishop to d3
capoblanca continues developing bishop
to b7 and now castles we have queen to
e8 uh now uh uh preparing to shift to
the queen over uh to the queen to the
kings side and now queen to e2
copablanca develops the queen connects
the rooks and it is now already as of
move nine that this position has never
been reached again
uh and black says all right now it's
time to go after the trades so knight
the e4 now trying to trade off
everything uh and here we have bishop
captures an e7 and now uh knight
captures in c3 and this character is not
really in the spirit of modern chess
queen captures on e7 would be would be a
little bit more precise because you
never expect white to capture here white
will try something like
when the time is right something like
knight after d2 and then he will try to
kick away your knight with f3 but this
is something you should force white to
do because it weakens uh
white's king side a little bit uh it
strengthens his center but you know it's
it's a trade-off but uh here if you
trade the uh
you cannot capture with the knight if
you capture with the knight then just
pawn captures and then well both the
knight and the bishop are attacked so
here it's very unlikely that we would
see bishop captures uh f captures and
then okay the knight has to move knight
to d2 black and strike in the center
with d5 and it's a very very
passive for for white and black has a
very clear way of what he wants to do
the queen now has access to the game the
other row can come to f8 so it's uh very
very enjoyable for black so maybe not
going for this trade right away but okay
knight captures on c3 this is 1924 after
all or maybe he wanted to surprise um uh
capablanca a little bit as tatakov there
was no uh pushover himself he was an
extremely strong player so b captures on
c3 queen captures on e7 and now
capablanca grabs more space on the queen
side with a4
and now how do you continue this with
black obviously you have to continue
development you need to bring your
knight into the game you look into the
game and uh but it's not all that clear
how to do this uh obviously g6 will be
played at some point uh but uh maybe
something like queen to f7 if you want
to try and get the queen into the attack
you could try and play an attacking game
utilizing this bishop as an attacking
piece for example now white can play a5
you're going to play queen to g6 and
you're always going to have this grip
on the g2 square but uh again
white can just play knight h4 kick away
the queen then play g3 and there's
really no attack here so instead uh
tartago replaced something completely
different here he just wants to trade
pieces against capoblanca so uh he just
wants to go into the end game as soon as
possible against capablanca so bishop
captures an f3 queen captures an f3 and
now knight to c6 we have to develop as
our rook on a8 is hanging so rook after
b1
now with some ideas of maybe weakening
the position with a5 or c5 depending on
what black does with the knight and the
queen so
rook 8 to e8 and now queen to h3 kappa
blanca puts some pressure on that h7
pawn but that's not what he really wants
to do he wants to grab a firm grip on
over the e5 square he wants to play f4
and then prevent black from executing
e5 himself because now if you play e5
then the f5 pawn just uh
hangs so here we have rook to f6
preparing to bring the rook to g6 or h6
again depending on what kappa blanca
plays and now f4 grabbing now the
control over the e5 square knights the
a5 tactical now says all right you will
not be achieving anything on the queen
side then we have queen back to f3 and
now we have d6 and this d6 move might be
a little too slow but even if you try uh
with the more direct approach let's say
c5 you challenge the center we're gonna
play e4 of course you don't wanna you
could always capture here and then play
something like like g6 the uh to prevent
anything happening to your king but even
here for example c captures on d4 if e5
we're going to move the rook and once he
captures on d4 was played this can
also definitely be played for black so
maybe c5 a little bit more precise but
okay here we have d6 and now capablanca
brings the rook back to e1 now he's
preparing e4
we have queen to d7 uh getting the queen
away from the e file and now comes pawn
to e4 as planned we have f captures on
e4 queen captures on e4 now attacking h7
and the g6 now so nothing wrong with
this this is perfectly fine for black g3
now adding a defender to his g3 pawn and
now king to f8
uh so what do you what do you do here
with white well capablanca starts by
bringing the king into the game as he is
uh preparing uh his pieces to enter the
end game we have rook to f7 uh sort of a
waiting move for black but you have to
play something now capoblanca grabs more
space on the king side we have h4 and
now d5 striking in the center uh we've
uh or rather uh you could also play
knight captures on c4 yeah it's
definitely worth mentioning because if
bishop captures then d5 gets an attack
on the bishop and the queen but here
white's plan is just
continue pushing and now uh things are
not looking all that great for black
we're gonna have to play d5 here and
once the queen moves it's still
very very suspicious for for black on
the king's side but it would be it would
definitely be a fighting idea here d5
was played immediately now kapolanka
captures on d5 with e captures on the e5
and now uh of course as a queen trade is
offered capablanca accepts it uh because
there is one very specific idea that he
had in mind so queen captures an e8
check queen captures rook capture 78
king capture 78 and now we've reached
the end game where it's the bishop and
rook against the knight and rook same
amount of pawns uh kings are fairly
similarly active the black king can you
know easily reach the center of the
board so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the idea cover
blank ahead and why he wanted to to go
into the end game at this precise moment
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations i imagine you spend
your days studying the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is ponte h5 you could also start
with rook to h1 and then pawn to h5 but
it's way cooler to play h5 right away so
what do you do here uh alejand says that
uh or rather in his words this is the
calamity the rook now enters the hostile
camp uh and if we capture this then just
rook h1 we're gonna pick up this spawn
then we're gonna pick up this pawn and
then we will have a a winning end game
so instead after h5 we have rook to f6
the rook will be much needed here
guarding the g6 square but also it can
easily be shifted to c6 going after the
c3 weakness so here we have h captures
on g6 h captures in the now of course
rook to h1 that was kappa blanca's plan
uh and now what do you what do you play
here well uh king the f8 it's a bit of a
bit of a slow move but um tartakover
plays it correctly as you are expecting
the rook to come to h6 so you need to
defend it with king
g7 there's no other way to defend g6 uh
and also uh if something like rook to h7
you can block with with rook to f7 so
here capablanca brings the rook to h7
but now not blocking with rook to f7 but
going for an active sort of an active
defense rook to c6 now attacks the c3
pawn
but capoblanca just plays g4 and now
here
with pushing g4 capablanca has a very
specific position in mind that it's uh
very hard for
for black to
uh
well to avoid uh here we have uh knight
to c4
if you just go for rook captures on c3
then you no longer defend the g6 pawn
kappa blanco will capture and now you
have two connected past pawns this is uh
just resigns so instead uh after g4 we
have knight to c4 and now g5 again uh
black can win some pawns here but it's
not uh
it's it's simply not enough here knight
to e3 check we have king to f3 and now
knight to f5 blocking the bishops attack
to the to the g6 pawn but this is not
the the absolute best way to defend this
position i will show it uh just um uh to
give you an example of how rich the game
really is uh knight to d1 is the way to
go now the idea is after rook to h6
going after the g6 pawn king to g7 and
now f5 that's that's the good stuff now
knight the b2 going after the bishop and
now bishop back to b1 if you guys are
thinking about f6 of course this doesn't
work rook captures an f6 and you've
blundered your advantage away captures
captures and you will not be winning
this with white so after the knight
attacks the bishop you're going to have
to move the bishop back and now of
course we're going to play rook captures
on c3 king g4 g captures and now bishop
captures on f5 and now with the rook
bishop passport and king uh ready to
jump into the game uh it will be very
hard for for black to defend this but it
will be possible that's what black
should have done so instead uh knight to
f5 was played but now it is very very
straightforward because here capablanca
can get the exact position he had in
mind uh when he uh probably even when he
played that h5 move so here bishop
captures an f5 uh alejan says that this
is well just simple and compelling and
now g captures on f5
uh so while uh
uh it's not something you can avoid uh
recapturing uh it's also uh well
completely lost for black but it's not
easy to figure out why so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
winning move for capoblanca while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not doing
anything weird like maybe you know
bringing the king back or or maybe
trying to you know
give a check or something like that or
pushing g6 because that just blunders
the pawn and for those of you who found
the move congratulations on being a true
master of the end game and that is king
to g3
that's the good stuff because now when
you see it of course you also believe it
uh the pawn here controls the e4 and the
g4 squares and if rook captures on c3
comes with check we're not going to be
able to go up the board with the king
we're going to have to go down the board
and that's well that's not how you
usually want to play the end game
sometimes it is but most of the times
it's not so kink to g3 now we have
access to the uh to the game uh and here
we have rook captures on c3 with check
king to h4 and now rook to f3 so you can
defend the pawn because the g4 square is
covered by the pawn
but this is all uh
planned by capoblanca because he will
get the position that he had in mind g6
rook captures on f4 and now king g5 with
tempo attacking the rook rook to e4 and
now king to f6 so this is the position
that capablanca had in mind king and f6
king gonna fade the pass pawn on g6 and
the rook on h7 and it's impossible to
defend this so
what what can you do here okay king g8
we're gonna try something uh but now
before capturing the c7 pawn uh we're
gonna play rook to g6 rook to g7 first
we want the king either an h8 or an f8
to be able to deliver this g6
push with check and uh alejan also
mentions about uh this position that
when capablanca started his march with
the king he of course knew that he would
get this position and that
the black pawns are you know in such a
uh such a terrible position that they
will tumble like ripe apples so here
king to h8 now comes rook captures on c7
and once you see this the king and pawn
controlling all of these squares you
just know that there's no way out
we have rook to e8 of course we have to
prevent checkmate and then now comes
king captures on f5 again um
simple and elegant as capablanca usually
plays because if you go for king to f7
it will just prolong the game
unnecessarily for example rook to d8 and
now okay you can play rook to c1 to try
and deliver checkmate this way but now
rook d7 check and how are you getting
out of checks without giving up the uh
the g8 square for the black king you're
going to have to play king e6 and once
rook d8 comes then you will capture the
pawn so instead of going uh all the way
around uh capoblanca just captures the
pawn he plays king captures on f5 we
have rook to e4 now trying to go behind
the white king once both the king and
pawn start marching forward but it will
of course be a futile rook for check
king to e5 now we have rooked the g for
attacking the pawn and now
it seems that tartakover
solved his problems because now the g7
square is covered twice by the rook and
by the pawn if the pawn is pushed of
course but that's exactly what
capoblanca does pawn to g7 because now
even with the rooks of the board and
giving up a pawn temporarily uh the
white king is much more active and will
be able to gobble up all of the pawns to
give you
an example captures captures captures
we're capturing here and look at the
white king easily uh gobbling up all of
these pawns for example and
promoting the past a pawn so instead
after g7 we have king to g8 and now we
have rook captures on a7 like alejan
said they are dropping like ripe apples
so we have rook to g1 now comes king
captures on d5 we have rook to c1 now
king to d6 now the d pawn is marching
forward rook to c2 black can only wait
uh and see what happens d feinbrook to
c1 rook to c7 now offering a rook trade
and row k1
it's not much but at least we will play
something king the c6 rook captures on
a4 and now d6 uh and it was in this
position on move 52 that tartan resigned
the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so we will show uh how this is um uh how
easy it is to win this because i know
some of you really enjoy it when we play
out the games until the end for example
rook d4 we're gonna try and put a rook
behind the pass pawn just d7 and if now
rook d3 we're gonna play king captures
on b6 that pawn is falling whatever
black does rogue b3 check king to c6
rook c3 check king b7 and now again
after rook d3 guarding the queening
square just king c8 and that's it we
queen the pawn on the next move and uh
of course we win the game easily
so yeah there you have it uh how how
simple the end game is when you really
understand chess and it's something that
uh
well i definitely agree with because uh
i've never studied the openings all that
much but i have studied the end game
quite a lot and even though uh when i
play classical game i uh like 99 percent
of the times i get outplayed in the
opening i get uh you know a a hard
position to play in the middle game but
if i reach the end game then somehow i i
always uh survive or or even triumph as
it's a it's a really exciting part of
the game so
if you you know like couple blanca's
idea maybe study the end game first then
you know enjoy some positions from the
middle game and only then when you're
rated 20
300 maybe you should dive uh deep into
the openings or maybe even higher rated
who knows what what the threshold is
nowadays uh so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it and that you've
uh
learned not the end game but that you've
learned maybe to appreciate the end game
a little more so uh there's that uh i
would like to um uh thank uh congrats
for the new job elizabeth
greetings uh from sravco booth zoolong
clothbooks.com and lucastiocardis for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the grand prix until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day